when you touch an object and it feels
warm or cold
what is that really telling you about
the object here I have a metal hard
drive and a book and I'm gonna ask
people to compare their temperatures
which one do you think will feel warmer
the book or the hard drive the 10
pitches yeah tell me if one is hotter or
colder or if they're the same
temperature how do they feel this is
slightly cooler than this one yeah
that's cool man yeah my yeah I agree
outside the hard drive is a lot colder
than the book um I don't know cuz the
books got more knowledge why do you
think that is
metals normally a little bit chillier if
you leave it in a colder temperature
well what if I said that there brother
the same temperature what would you say
so you're buying but really you think
you're lying
yeah oh Jesus well maybe the way I could
prove it is I have infrared thermometer
what do you think we're gonna see let's
think sign smart the other name for that
and I'm not a scientist I like a
prediction for me I still think that
that that's cold would you get me money
I do it because I don't have any cash
let's measure the temperature of the
book okay what do you see
19 5 0 K I measure the temperature of
that 19.0 I will now I believe I'm
trying to get you figure it out actually
try to figure out why there would be the
same temperature that I didn't feel the
same temperature that so why does that
feel colder if they're basically the
same good one you're the answer ha ha
I'm coming to you guys Francis we're
creatives not intellectuals for create
an answer for me I'm sorry I just go on
you tell me well I'll try to answer that
question with another little experiment
here is an aluminium block and nice and
close a plastic block
how do they temperatures compare
completely different well lately much
photo yeah yeah this actually feels
colder let's take this to the next level
I'm gonna put an ice cube on both plates
what are we gonna sing well I'm guessing
it would stay solid on this one and melt
on this one so it's going to melt on the
plastic but stay solid on the alamin you
yes and maybe I'm wrong
that one will melt more quickly than on
the aluminium block yes see sitting in
the cold oh yeah cause it's cold let's
actually make it a guy design alright so
we put an ice cube on each of those
blocks wha what are you seeing well it
is melting a lot quicker on the
aluminium I got his melting given then
not one even notices aluminium that's
custody so which one felt colder that
one how does that make any sense I have
no idea aluminium be bad for the
environment
how would aluminium be bad for the
environment well it's storing at the
ocelot quickly reason so you want the
answer yes please
it's about thermal conductivity right
the rate at which heat is transferred
from one object to another so when you
felt these blocks originally I know this
one felt a lot colder yeah but you know
from the other example we did that they
must both be at the same temperature
truth is they both been outside for a
while we see that the aluminium block is
melting the ice faster than the plastic
block because it's conducting the heat
to the Ice Cube faster okay with the
plastic block it's a worse thermal
conductor so heat is being transferred
less quickly to this ice block and so
it's staying ice okay I believe you
mmm-hmm make sense yes you know in our
first example the hard drive felt colder
even though it was at the same
temperature roughly as the book and
that's because the aluminium conducts
heat away from your hand faster than the
book conducts heat away from your hand
sure that seems logical which makes the
the hard drive feel colder and the book
feel warmer yes so when you touch
something you don't actually feel
temperature you feel the rate at which
heat is conducted either towards or away
from you think about this next time you
hop out of the shower in winter it's
much nicer to stand on the bath mat than
on the tile beside it not because the
bath mat is warmer but because it
conducts heat less quickly away from you